INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So picking up where
we left off last time,
we set up our RDS instance.
And we were able to
connect to it via Python,
so on an EC2 instance.
So I'm basically
starting from that point.
So if you maybe deleted your
RDS instance, which is great,
thank you for doing that.
But if you did, if you want
to spin up a new one the way
we set up in the past two
lectures, that'd be great.
Basically, I'm getting
back to that point,
or I'm starting from that
point of, if we come here,
I have this table, this top 10s,
this top 10 songs are already
in here.
Here let me slide out the
way now so you can see it.
But I just have this
top 10 songs database
that we had used before
already loaded in there.
You don't have to go through
the steps to load the EC1,
I'm just going to do this with
the top 10s data set when we
just load it via
the import wizard.
But if you want, you can
do it with the EC1 as well.
So you're more welcome
to do it either way.
But what I want
to show you today
is the piece of the
puzzle that connects
the last couple of weeks of
stuff we've been working on.
In the previous module, we
developed and deployed the API
on a website.
And now I want to show you how
to basically connect that API
to this RDS database instance.
The reason being is, I think
this is one of those ideas
that you might be
surprised could actually
be a business today.
To some extent,
data is a resource.
I would argue that it's arguably
the most important resource
right now in at least the modern
industry or working world.
And a lot of companies have
been developed and constructed,
purely around having the
best data, the best data set.
And one aspect of that is,
you could just provide access
to your data, that might
be enough of a resource
to drive value.
And there's two ways you can
go about deploying or providing
access to that data set.
One of the simplest way
would be to say, OK, well,
maybe it's a big spreadsheet
that I have up in S3,
and I just say you can
download the whole spreadsheet
if you pay me 100 bucks.
That's one thing,
but it first off
means that there's no
ongoing revenue stream,
they're just going
to download it once
and then they have everything.
On the other side of it,
from the user standpoint,
it's also potentially not
the cleanest interface.
Maybe the service you
provide is structuring
and making this data easily
searchable and queryable.
And so you might have some
really well built-out database.
Maybe it's hosted
in an RDS instance.
So you have this really well
built-out database, everything's
in nice structured columns.
And so maybe the user just
wants to go in and say,
well, I need to grab all
of the songs from 2010.
Obviously this is
a trivial example.
This is not the best
use-case for it,
but picture all the
ways, or all the
places that you may want
to have aggregated data
for your company, for
your organization.
And again, if they can
come in now and say,
hey, I want to access.
Or I want to hit
your API, I want
to make a request
to your API, and I
want to return that information,
and that information
is sitting in the database, then
I can actually just give them
some number of credits,
some number of requests
per dollar to my data set.
This is one of the ways, one
of the biggest ways that data
ends up being monetized.
And so I want you guys
to take this to heart,
because you may want to do this
even for your final project.
I know some of you have already
probably submitted your,
or should have already submitted
your project proposals.
But even if you
haven't, or you decide,
hey, maybe I want
to pivot or I want
to add this on to it, that's
perfectly OK as well, we're
going to constantly
talk about new things.
So if down the line,
you're like, actually,
I'd rather do this for my
final project, that's great,
go for it.
The project proposal
is just to get you
guys start thinking about this.
But either way, this is
where we're picking up from.
And I'm also picking
up from the point
that I've already-- here, let
me zoom in on my terminal here.
--I've already set
up my EC2 instance.
So this is all the stuff that
I did in the previous lecture.
So installed the AWS command
line interface, set up
some of these SQL functions,
or some of these Python
files, Python scripts.
You don't need to worry
about doing all these,
we're going to do an
entirely separate one today.
But I have, I believe,
already installed PIP.
So again, all this stuff was
the stuff I did in Lecture 18.
Walk back through those
notes-- or sorry, Lecture 19,
got the numbers mixed up.
But either walk back
through those notes,
get those things set up.
And if something doesn't work,
when you're going through this,
it might be that you just missed
a step from a previous one.
So look into that.
But either way, picking up
from there, the first thing we
need to do--
and again, all these notes are
in that lecture 19 RDS with API
notes sheet.
It's a relatively short one.
So hopefully, if
you're able to get
through all this stuff
in the previous steps,
this should be a really quick
tack on to the end of that.
But if not, it might
be a little longer,
because you're getting
back into seed.
So either way, you'll see
the first thing it suggests
is creating an EC2 instance.
I'm assuming we've
already done that.
Then it says we need
to set up this API.
We want to actually build
the API the same way
we built it in Lecture 15.
So I'm going to show you
guys how to do that now.
And so it's going
to follow roughly
along with the lecture 15 notes,
starting from the install flask
section.
But we're going to
modify a few things.
So if something doesn't look
exactly the same, that's why.
But either way,
picking up from there.
So again, we already
have PIP installed.
You can even check that.
If you do, I think if we do
PIP version it should show.
Yep, so we see you have
PIP installed there.
So first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to make,
I don't know, maybe I'll
call it a different thing,
rather than call it
PersonalAPI, I call it SongAPI.
I'm going to make a
directory called SongAPI.
And on a CD into SongAPI, I'm
going to run sudo apt install
python3.8-v. Actually we
don't even need to do virtual
environment right now.
Let's not even waste time
with the virtual environments,
let's just jump ahead.
You could again, do a
virtual environment.
But we can also just do this
in the main environment,
we're not going to be
doing anything different.
So I just did pip install
flask, if you didn't see that.
I'm just skipping ahead
to pip install flask.
Then I'm going to create
my api.py file, api.py.
So vi.api.py.
And so, if you remember
in the previous code
we had these first few lines.
And we'll leave these the same.
So I'm just copying and paste
these from lecture 15 notes.
We're importing
flask, and here I'll
just remove these comments
since we don't really
need them anymore.
We know what we're
doing with this.
So we're going to
remove these comments.
And then the next chunk of
code, starting from @app.route,
rather than doing the Get method
that we had in the lecture 15,
we're going to do the
Get method that we have
or that I put in the
notes for the lecture 19.
So I'm just going to
copy and paste that.
Copy there.
And so you'll see that starting
from the top, we're saying,
if you hit this exact route,
api/v1/resources/songs with
the Get method.
The song_year is going to be the
function that we've created now.
So if you hit this, it's going
to run this song_year function.
Then what it's
going to do is it's
going to check to
see if you passed
any argument called the year.
If you pass the year argument,
then it will run this.
It'll say, OK.
Well, I'm going to create this
new variable called the year,
and it's going to be the
integer of whatever the argument
that you pass to year is.
And remember, we'll show how--
I'll show you how to
pass that argument.
But we did that in the URL
itself with the question mark.
If you don't have
a year in there,
it's going to return
an error and say
we didn't provide a year,
and so please specify a year.
And so the hope is that when
we actually go to run this,
you'll see it initiates
this RDS connection.
So actually, you
need to make sure you
go through the steps
in the previous lecture
to create the
start_rds_connection file.
But it's going to do-- and I'll
open up the start_rds_connection
again in here in a second so
you can see what that does.
But it's going to do
start_rds_connection.
And then with that connection,
we're going to run this query.
SELECT everything
FROM top10s, which
is the name of our
database, WHERE
the year is equal to,
curly braces, year.
And so by doing this
f, this is where
we did the formatted string,
what the unnecessary steps
because I copied and paste-- for
the previous lecture, I copied
and pasted from this lecture.
So we didn't need a
formatted string there
because we were just doing
select everything from top10s.
But now we're passing
something into that.
And so by doing f
and then passing
this in the curly
braces, it's going
to put that year into there.
From there, we're just
going to execute the SQL,
fetch the results, and return
the results as JSON, OK?
Because remember,
we said that it's
a little easier to
work with the JSON
if I'm hitting an API
to just get it all back
as opposed to HTML back.
So that's what
we're doing there.
So OK.
That all looks good.
And then if we just vi start--
oops, what was it again?
I already forgot the
name of the function.
Yes, start_rds_connection.
Oh, that's why.
So start_rds_connection.
Oh, actually, we call
just ours rds_connection.
So let me see here.
So I know it's going
to need to happen.
So these are some steps that
I'll need to add into the notes.
Your notes should
look better now.
But what I want to do is I want
to add a start_rds function
to my directory that I
created that song API.
And I believe, if
I'm not mistaken,
it's just the same as these.
Yeah.
So we want to create this
start_rds function, just
this part here and not
the actual down here.
So what I'm going to do is--
let me pause for a
second and make sure
I do this next step right so
it's a little bit smoother
for you guys, but I'll
be back in 2 seconds.
All right.
So back 2 seconds later.
It's the difficult part
about trying to read my notes
as well as talk
at the same time.
My notes actually did have
what I wanted to do in there.
So the only thing
I need to do is,
because I'm running this
in that project file,
that SongAPI directory,
I'm going to, in there,
open up my api.py file again.
And I need to actually
just add a function called
start_rds_connection to this.
And that is the same function
we did in the lecture 18 notes.
So if you pull up
lecture 18 notes, which
I'm going to do right now--
and I'll pull it up on
the screen as well too.
Let me see where it's at.
Might be towards the bottom.
Yeah, so here we go.
So I'll drag this up on the
screen so you can see it.
So this is just coming
from the lecture 18 notes.
First, I'm going to
do I in my terminal,
so I can insert something.
And then over here, in
the lecture 18 notes,
under this upload
data to EC2 table
or to a table EC2
instance, I'm just
going to copy and
paste this function.
And I'll just
paste it over here.
So you see now that up here when
we call start_rds_connection--
I'll go to-- when we call
start_rds_connection,
it now has this function
in the code here.
This is going to grab
all the relevant files
from our directories.
Now, one thing to note is--
and actually make sure we
don't need any extra import
statements.
We might actually need to
import statements here.
So let me copy these ones here.
Copy these two imports,
put those in there as well.
And so now, we should be good.
Now, the only thing
to note though
is that the config file is
sitting in our home directory,
not in our project directory,
as is our SSL file.
Our SSL, Or Secure
Security Certificate.
So I'm going to put
those in the file
or in this SongAPI directory.
So again, see that
there's nothing
other than the
api.py file in there.
Oops.
And we need to have both--
where is it at?
This SSL as well
as this config.py
in our SongAPI directory.
So I'm actually just going
to use the copy command.
So I'm going to say copy
config.py to SongAPI.
I think this should work.
Or actually, let's
do it this way.
It's a little easier syntax wise
if I'm in the right directory.
So I'll go in the SongAPI and
I'll do copytilde/config.py
to here, here being the period.
And so we should have
that in there now.
And then similarly, I'm going
to copy the SSL security
certificate into this
directory, but I'm
going to make an SSL
directory in here too.
You don't have to
do it this way.
Again, a million different ways
you could do this, but this
is just the easiest way for me.
So I'm going to do CP SSL,
rsd-combined-ca-bundle.pem,
period.
Now that's there.
And if we look in SongAPI,
that should be there.
So my gut feeling is that this
should be able to work now,
but we'll see here in a second.
So we've already
installed Flask,
so let's do our export
FLASK_APP=api.py.
And then let's do flask
run//host=0.0.0.0.
Hit Enter.
And now, if this
worked correctly,
go to my EC2 instance,
and let me make sure
it's the right one that I'm on.
I believe so, yes.
SharadRDSDemo.
So let's grab the IPv4:, and
we'll go 5000/ and, let's see,
our path was
APIv1resourcessongs,
then I Enter.
And it should have
thrown a different error.
Let me see.
Let me pause real
quick and come back
and make sure I did
the right thing here.
OK.
Because I want you guys
to start recognizing
the value of learning
how to debug this stuff,
I'll show you what
I'm doing actually,
as opposed to just me
figuring it out in isolation.
So I have this error.
It's not the error I expect.
And the reason I'll tell
you that or the reason
I know that is, if
you remember, when
we created the file or
created the function, we said
that if we didn't pass a year
to it, which we didn't do here,
it should say, hey,
there's an error.
You didn't pass a
year, pass a year.
This internal server
error tells me
something didn't work right
on the server side of things,
on the pushing this
to the website.
So I'm going to actually
go to the terminal.
And if I go to the
terminal, you'll
see that, again, I have
just launched my app.
It was showing here.
But after I went to run this
web page, it put in a timestamp
here and said, hey, actually
this error happened.
This was the server error.
So if I look in my
code, I'll see that, OK,
it says that in line 11,
in song_year, if year
in request.args, that was the
line that we put in the code.
It's saying, hey, I don't
know what request is.
I didn't tell it
what request was.
So we'll do Control-C
to close out of this.
We'll do vi api.py.
And if you remember--
I'll do insert, we not only
need it to import flask.
And when we did the
requests-- and actually,
the JSON file as well
would have thrown an error
if that had come first.
We need to do, from flask,
import request and jsonify.
That should be better now.
So let's run this and see
what error we get now.
The hope is you
just get an error
and then you see what happens,
you get error, see what happens,
and all that.
So now that's what it says.
OK.
Well let's refresh this.
Great.
So if you can't see that
here, it says, error.
No year provided.
Please specify a year.
The reason I'm OK
with this error is,
again, this is the
error that we wrote.
That means that our app
ran, and the error statement
that we created broke.
So somewhere in our code
here-- so let's go to--
let's just Control-C
for one second,
and I'm just going
to open in my app.
That means that everything
above this ran correctly,
it was just right here that we
didn't pass a year argument.
But we got into this function.
Getting into this
function tells me
that, great, something happened.
So let's try this
one more time now.
We'll do flask run.
But now, rather than
not specifying a year,
we will put in a year.
So if you remember, all we
have to do to pass the year
or pass some argument to
this is do question mark
and then put what the
thing is we want to pass.
And we'll say year
equal to 2010.
And there we go.
So now, we have-- the
first column is unknown,
but you can see the JSON
file here says, OK, great.
We have an acoustic column, an
artist, bpm, decibels, dance,
all this stuff.
And this is actually the data.
And you can see even
that if we come in here,
the years should always be
2010, because all of these
are the ones that, in our
data set, had come 2010.
This is exactly identical to
if we were on this query window
here just saying,
where year equals 2010,
and running this query.
Those two things are
exactly identical.
You see the first line
here, it gets pulled in.
It says, hey, Soul
Sister by train.
And this is the same
one happened here.
And again, I want you
to recognize-- here,
I'll do this in an incognito
window to hammer home the point.
So let me copy this there.
We'll go to an incognito
window for a second here.
And even an incognito
window, this query ran.
So that means that from
anywhere on the internet
now, if this is live, I
could type in this exact URL
and get returned
this information.
And so this is the
kind of power that we
have now at our fingertips
with using these RDS
instances with our database.
Or better statement,
this is the power
of using pairing need of the
website development side of this
with the RDS instance.
Is now we can actually
build something.
Before if you look back in
your lecture 15 code, we put--
I'll drag it up
here on the screen.
We put the information
about the drivers
or whatever the data
set you're using,
we put that into
the Python function,
which means that we wouldn't
have to type out everything
here.
This is not a
structured database.
We don't have the power of this.
What we've done
now is we've said,
hey, we actually
can put a database
on the backend of our
website, and now query to it,
make run queries.
And the important
thing to recognize
is this was just a get request.
This was us just
saying-- remember
we said there's a match between
the get requests and read,
reading something
from a SQL file?
We can also do
some put or update,
and those would be
more like a right step.
So now maybe you
have something where
a user comes to your
website, and you
have a text box that they can
fill in and put information
about themselves, user
information, and hit Submit.
And now that submit would update
your database on the backend.
This is how companies create
the databases that power
their websites, that power
everything that they do,
is when a customer
goes to buy a product.
When somebody goes to buy
a product on amazon.com,
they're using AWS in
the backend certainly.
And so that person
makes the purchase.
They put in their payment
information, their billing
location, shipping
address, all that stuff.
And then all that
information when
they hit Purchase this,
that's going to push off,
run some query that
updates their data set.
So now they know,
hey, this person
bought on this date
and this information.
That's really the power
that we have here.
So I want you guys to
keep this in your head.
Think about the projects
you can build with this.
Maybe consider adding
this to your project.
Again, a fairly straightforward
process I would argue.
Yeah, there's some
legwork in getting
the RDS instances set up.
I believe in you guys.
You can do that.
You've already been
able to do the EC2
instances and deploying
websites that way.
And again, importantly,
you can deploy your website
in any way you want.
All we're doing is passing
an ending to this URL.
That is the only thing
that makes this unique.
But if you have some
other website that
has an actual URL
and all that, great,
you would just tack this on,
add this as another page,
build a Flask app to do this.
So many options at
your fingertips now.
So I hope this excites you
guys as much as it does for me.
I arguably wish I had learned
a lot of stuff earlier on.
It really lets you expand the
capacity of what you can do, OK?
I'll leave it at that.
We'll pick back up
next time with a few
more things on the
database side of things,
but it'll be a slow transition
into analytics workloads.
So this is the end
of RDS instances.
Next, we'll see Redshift,
again, which is leaning more
towards the analytics
side, and then we'll
finish off this semester talking
analytics and machine learning
and all that great
stuff, the things
that I'm really, really
passionate about, OK?
So hopefully, this is helpful.
Please let me know if you have
any questions or any issues come
up, OK?
Bye.